Hangover cures-- science
has got the real deal.
And I know you need
them, you drunks.
Hey, everyone, Laci
Green here for D News.
There are 101
hangover cures that
have been passed
down through the ages
by those older, wiser,
and drunker than us.
And now scientists
are adding to the mix.
A new study published in the
journal Food and Function
took a good, hard look at how
various non-alcoholic beverages
affect a hangover, 57 different
beverages, actually, including
herbal teas and
carbonated drinks.
And what was the winner of
a hangover helper trials?
It was Sprite.
First, I was like, OK,
did Sprite fund this?
Or what's up?
But they actually did not fund
the study's favorable findings,
so I guess I'll
give it a chance.
In order to understand
how Sprite of all things
helps a hangover, first, we
got to talk about hangovers,
my favorite subject in
the world, basically.
Hangovers aren't caused by
booze itself, but by the way
your body breaks it down.
While you're passed
out on the couch,
your liver is breaking
down the alcohol,
which produces an
absolutely evil chemical
byproduct called acetyldehyde.
This is a chemical is
responsible for cute things,
like headaches, light
sensitivity, thirst, sweat,
and vomiting.
Eventually your body converts
acetyldehyde to acetate,
which means no more
hangover for you.
So in order to
eliminate a hangover,
you want to convert it to
acetate as fast as possible.
What they found was
that herbal teas
slow the activity of enzymes
that convert it over.
So just say no to herbal teas.
But Sprite-- and
actually use soda water
if you don't want all
the sugar-- speed up
the enzyme activity that's
needed to get over a hangover.
Not a fan of Sprite
or soda water?
Don't worry.
There are other remedies
that help clear acetyldehyde
from the body.
Apparently there's a famous
soup from New Orleans
called yaka mein soup.
It has a salty broth, some
kind of meat, chicken or beef,
onions, and a sliced egg.
Scientists at UC
Davis say there's
a reason this soup
is called Old Sober.
The eggs in the soup help
to clear the acetyldehyde
from the body, while the
salty broth helps replace
important salts lost in all
the peeing you're doing,
which then speeds up
the recovery process.
Scientists say, however, that
the best hangover treatment
is not to get a hangover at all,
an important nugget of wisdom
I probably won't follow.
So you can prevent a hangover by
eating fatty foods to regulate
the body's absorption
of alcohol,
by drinking a glass of
water between drinks,
and by avoiding
dark drinks, which
have higher levels of
hangover-exacerbating
congeners.
So it is Friday,
the end of the week.
Let's put that scientific
wisdom to work.
Thanks for joining me, folks.
If you have your
own hangover cures,
you should share down below.
And we'll be back
with more D News soon.
See you then.